bonsoir frédéric française merci d'être
avec nous a souvent eu un ici sur cette
antenne vous étiez exaspéré aujourd'hui
quel est votre état d'esprit après cette
évacuation du jardin et hall
alors on n'est plus du tout exaspéré là
maintenant on est complètement désabusés
parce que effectivement on attendait
avec beaucoup de patience et beaucoup
d'espérance le le village du jardin mais
on s'attendait peut-être parce que les
toxicomanes soit pris en charge et
qu'ils soient pas laissés en errance
autour du jardin est en fait sous le nez
sous le nez des riverains là clairement
en fait on est complètement désabusé et
relativement énervé parce que en fait on
a l'impression de s'être fait prendre un
petit peu pour des imbéciles par la
mairie qui nous a fait des réunions
pendant un certain temps mais qui nous
anime donc effectivement le jardin
serait évacuée par contre on s'attendait
à ce que vraiment ils soient pris en
charge les toxicomanes que les dealers
soit peu arrêté par la police
et c'est vrai que le premier jour du
dispositif n'a pas donner réellement les
effets escomptés
ça veut dire quoi concrètement c'est que
tout simplement ces toxicomanes sont
sont déplacés ils ont été évacués vers
quoi vert ou aujourd'hui pour bien qu'on
comprenne alors qui se passe c'est
qu'ils n'ont pas du tout été évacués en
réalité ce qui s'est passé c'est que
hier soir le jardin fermé à une heure du
matin puisque ils lisent étaient
autorisés à y rester jusqu'à une heure
du matin jusqu'à hier soir donc à une
heure du matin et le parc à terme et la
police a essayé de les disperser vers
une heure du matin parce que bon voilà
ils sont toujours devant les l'avenue
riquet devant l'entrée de la rue riquet
et ce matin donc à 10 heures du matin le
la mairie n'a ouvert qu'une seule entrée
et à filtrer l'entrée
donc ils ont empêché les toxicomanes
d'entrer dans le parc en revanche aucune
solution n'a été trouvée pour les
toxicomanes on parle d'évacuation n'y a
pas eu d'évacuation à proprement parler
il ya eu juste en fait une offre un
empêchement des toxicomanes d'entrer
dans le parc en réalité
voilà ils sont en errance dans les rues
ils sont livrés à eux-mêmes donc ils ne
sont plus dans le parc effectivement ils
sont autour du parc dans les rues
adjacentes au pied des immeubles dans
les parkings il ya eu déjà en fait des
gros problème aujourd'hui dans le
quartier sans doute le plus triste dans
tout ça c'est que les riverains la
population parisienne évidemment
empathie mais on a vu dans ce témoignage
poignant que les toxicomanes sont
désespérés aussi ce monsieur évoqué son
pire cauchemar et que selon lui jamais
ils n'arriveront à nous déloger d'ici
tous
ils demandent même une mise au vert loin
de paris c'est une situation qui semble
inextricable
alors tout à fait c'est un petit peu
compliqué parce que il ya deux doctrines
qui sait qu'ils proposent c'est la
doctrine je dirais de la mairie de paris
qui est des médecins qui veulent
absolument passer par des salles de
consommation à moindre risque par un
encadrement de la consommation et une
diminution progressive et ce qui se
passe c'est que les toxicomanes de même
qu'ils sont donc des malades les
patients eux-mêmes dire je dirais eux
en fait on pas du tout envie d'avoir une
à un arrêt de progressif ou en
accompagnement la consommation ce qu'ils
veulent c'est arrêter totalement la
drogue donc ça pose un petit souci parce
qu'on a vu déjà sur le rapport de
l'inserm qui a été publié en début
d'année qu'il y avait en fait une une
divergence réel entre ce qui est
préconisé par les médecins et par la
mairie est ce que souhaite réellement
les toxicomanes donc sacré en fait
vraiment un énorme écart et du coup on
ne sait plus vraiment où on fait comment
faire quoi pour traiter ces gens
ce qu'on voudrait c'est qu'il soit
encadré effectivement après londres les
structures qui nous paraissent nous
hospitalière sais c'est qu'il leur faut
c'est une structure où il sera encadré
de façon ferme et je dirais pour qui à
partir du moment où ils concept rare
entrer dans le processus d'arrêt de la
drogue ils puissent être encadrés
soigner et surtout qui rechute pas donc
effectivement peut-être les éloigner de
paris ça peut être une solution
j'ai eu récemment une merde une
toxicomane qui m'a appelé et qui m'a
confirmé qu'effectivement le seul moyen
pour sa fille d'arrêter réellement la
drogue c'était de se quitter paris ne
revenir chez ses parents par contre 7
par an en fait on a un gros problème
c'est que quand il essaye de la faire
soigner donc par les moyens légaux je
dirais donc il faut passer il faut
quatre à cinq jours
ap les différents services pour pouvoir
arriver à ce que cette personne soit
donc prise en charge par les hôpitaux
par contre et c'est ce qu'elle mec simic
et cette maman c'est que les toxicomanes
ensuite ne peuvent très bien ressortir
aussi vite de l'hôpital c'est à dire
qu'elle a passé cinq jours à essayer de
la faire entrer dans l'hôpital et 24
heures après elle était déjà sorti parce
qu'il n'ya pas de surveillance et
laisser les hôpitaux ne sont pas fermées
et c'est vraiment ça qui est un problème
c'est il faut vraiment que ces personnes
soient encadrés et qu'elle ne puisse pas
sortir du lieu de soins parce que sinon
on retourne directement par les dealers
et dont on consomme est clairement
aujourd'hui on sent une impuissance de
de l'état lui même chacun se renvoie la
balle à la mairie de paris le
gouvernement
là on tente de vous rassurer en disant
pour éviter de nouveaux rassemblements
dans la zone de stalingrad
on va renforcer la présence policière
ça semble absurde on c'est un début de
solution pour vous pour nous c'est juste
absurde en fait la pole la présence
policière tout ce que ça fait c'est
déplacer le problème
les policiers ne sont pas là pour en
prendre en charge les toxicomanes et ils
peuvent pas les soigner tout ce qu'ils
peuvent faire c'est éventuellement donc
est déplacé leur demander de ne pas
rester ne vous aime pas consommer en
fait dans la rue éventuellement arrêter
les dealers mais il faudrait vraiment
s'il a retrouvé à ces toxicomanes à une
solution de repli
il faut qu'ils puissent être encadrés
dans un lieu en dehors de paris en
dehors en tout cas des riverains
relativement loin des riverains dans une
zone industrielle par exemple pour
qu'ils soient en fait pris en charge
plus que plus pauvres plus enfin qu'il
soit simplement voilà de manière plus
efficace parce que l'actuel mans ce
qu'ils ont fait c'est les disperser dans
les rues et du cou avant c'était le
jardin qui était infréquentable même
c'est tout l'arrondissement qui va
devenir infréquentable puisque les 400
personnes n'ont pas disparu elles sont
justes en errance dans les rues et elles
sont très dangereuses a priori merci en
tout cas frédéric france elle porte
parole du collectif 19 d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france